non nascondo la la forte emozione
dell'essere qui quando gli è stato
chiesto
di fare un intervento appunto intorno
alla parola upgrade la prima domanda che
mi sono fatto è stata ma che cosa vado a
dire che cosa devo dire e mi sono reso
conto
riflettendosi stare ponendomi la domanda
sbagliata
il la domanda non è che cosa devo dire
ma devo aver qualcosa da dire io sono
insegnante e insegnare significa
lasciare segni non è dentro qualcuno
e quindi la mia
non va avanti
ecco
mi sono appellato a questa
citazione che che mi sta tantissimo
cuore di sant'ignazio di antiochia lo
metto tra parentesi santo perché per
alcuni può essere santo per altri no a
seconda del proprio credo ha segnati di
antiochia che cosa si diceva diceva si
insegna molto con ciò che si dice ancora
di più con quello che si fa molto di che
si insegna con ciò che si è e quindi ci
invita a tristi minare a dare
testimonianza di ciò che siamo portare
la nostra essenza e quello che ho fatto
oggi è stata portare a punto la niente
tachis one la mia testimonianza
mi chiamo sacco visconti e lo scritto
perché dall'emozione dito paura di
dimenticarmi chi sono e quando sono nato
nato nel classe 1991 quindi 30 anni e
questo è il mio curricolo e il mio
percorso scolastico o appunto fatto
quando ancora c'era e si dava appunto
design l'esame alle scuole elementari ho
fatto l'esame sono uscito con ottimo poi
è ottimo l'ho preso anche all l'esame di
licenza media
mi sono laureato
alla maturità classica con 82 centesimi
poi mi sono laureato alla triennale qui
all'alma mater studiorum di bologna con
una tesi su dante in tutti i sensi nel
senso che sia su dante alighieri che su
dante proprio per quanto mi ha
consumato e poi è una con una tesi
magistrale su francesco petrarca sulla
dieta di francesco petrarca o mi sono
laureato con 110 e lode poi è presso
l'archivio di stato di bologna e ho
conseguito il diploma in archivistica
paleografia e diplomatica ha preso
appunto l'archivio di stato
e la domanda che mi sono posto è se
questo questo questa fotografia questo
mio percorso questo mio curriculum sia
di fatto un upgrade ma la domanda ancora
una volta spesso ci poniamo domande
sbagliate
prima di dare questa risposta e mi sono
chiesto che cos'è un upgrade parto da
una delle teorie
diffuse in italia da un libro di howard
gardner si chiama forme mentis dove
appunto è indicativo questo forme al
plurale e il quale ora garner si dice e
non esiste un tipo di intelligenza per
intelligenza appunto partendo
dall'etimologia
intelligere significa proprio
comprendere dice ci sono diversi modi di
essere intelligenti cioè di comprendere
il mondo c'è l'intelligenza linguistica
quella interpersonale quella
intrapersonale esiste un intelligenza
musicale logico matematica
cinestetica legata al movimento quindi
si può comprendere il mondo in diversi
modi quello che ho scoperto
nella mia esperienza e di avere maturato
un intelligenza linguistica e cioè
legata al linguaggio in che senso nel
senso che la parola il linguaggio per me
è veicolo di conoscenza io uso la parola
usa il linguaggio per comprendere il
mondo
e proprio per questo motivo ho deciso di
aprire questo questo evento cercando di
dare una definizione di upgrade partendo
appunto dall etimologia crede una parola
inglese e quindi di origine germanica e
siamo con l'inglese non siamo sorelle
con latino ma ciò con l'italiano ma in
virtù di questa nonna che lyndon europeo
questa lingua comune riusciamo a
recuperarne il latino qualche
qualche qualche consiglio che c'è
qualche indizio che ci aiuti appunto a
comprendere il significato di questa
parola c'è un verbo latino grad ur gr
there is gres sun gradi che significa
camminare procedere avanzare e dunque in
upgrade se sia l'elemento up verso
l'alto un qualcosa che ci rimanda verso
l'alto e poi se l'idea di movimento
perché appunto gradi or significa
camminare avanzare procedere e mi sono
dato
delle risposte tre possibili traduzioni
di questa parola la prima è progresso in
progresso sia ancora l'etimologia di di
gradi or progresso e progredire
significa andare però avanti e dunque
non è una traduzione che già questa
tradizione non mi soddisfaceva proprio
perché upgrade indica un movimento verso
l'alto
invece il progresso indica sì un
movimento però un movimento in avanti la
seconda possibile soluzione è stata
ascesa però penso alessi con la
semantica quand'è che usiamo il termine
ascesa in italiano ascesa al soglio
pontificio ascesa al trono
ascensione legata a cristo la madonna i
santi ascesa appunto al soglio
pontificio per un papa l'ascesa al trono
per per un imperatore dunque è un
termine che non ci appartiene per pochi
e per pochi eletti e noi appunto non
facciamo parte di questa di cristo se
n'è stato uno al mondo di papà se adesso
due però comunque è molto poco e su 7
miliardi che siamo e quindi non mi
convinceva neanche questo la terza
ipotesi è stata crescita ipotesi di
traduzione crescita appunto cresco è un
suffisso questo scopo un suffisso in
coattivo in latino indica un progressivo
cambiamento di stato dunque se si ha
l'idea di mosè sì l'idea di movimento
data da gr dior ma manca ancora qui
l'idea di movimento verso l'alto
e allora ho trovato la risposta secondo
me nella parola miglioramento e qui è
ovviamente uno si fa forte con quello
che sa ho trovato la risposta nella
letteratura ancora una volta nel
linguaggio ancora una volta in dante
nello specifico il dante della commedia
è ancora più nello specifico
nell'inferno dantesco gli dico sempre
perché c'è la mia ipotesi perché il
l'inferno ha avuto così tanto successo
nella nella storia letteraria italia
nella nella cultura scolastica italiana
credo che la risposta sia perché parla
di noi perché parlano e mentre il
paradiso ci presenta esseri perfetti e
dunque che non possono andare oltre
l'inferno mette in scena noi mette in
scena l'umanità mette in scena
l'imperfetto se il non compiuto quello
che ha appunto margine di miglioramento
nello specifico dante ci presenta due
modelli di viaggio dante si
presenta lui stesso nella commedia si
invita a fare una riflessione si invita
a fare un confronto un confronto con chi
con ulisse sono due viaggiatori entrambi
hanno un dono entrambi hanno il dono
della della parola dante usa la parola
usa questo talento per metterlo a
disposizione dell'umanità dante che cosa
fa con la commedia ci fa vedere
l'inferno e ci dice guarda se ti
comporti male succede questo e si fa
vedere il paradiso se ti comporti bene
succede quest'altro quindi usa un dono
che gli è stato dato dall alto e
desideri poi lo vedremo
e lo mette al servizio dell'umanità
ulisse invece
ha un talento anche lui
il talento è quello della parola secondo
me era chiusa nell'arte anche questa è
una mia interpretazione il fatto che il
e ulisse è racchiuso in una fiamma di
fuoco in inferno 26 è insieme a diomede
questo fuoco secondo me rappresenta
appunto la fiamma la passione il nostro
talento come la usa però come usa ulisse
però questo talento lo usa per prendersi
gioco degli altri tant'è che ha punito
nella commedia tra i consiglieri
fraudolenti
uno dei motivi per cui a punite appunto
il l'inganno del cavallo di [ __ ]
quindi dante e ulisse hanno entrambi un
dono che sfruttano in maniera diversa 1
a servizio dell'umanità e uno contro
contro il prossimo e hanno anche due
modi di viaggiare diversi ulisse in
inferno 26 e tra l'altro questo
confronto è dante stesso che ci invita a
farlo perché dante usa nella commedia un
aggettivo folle che lui e che usa per se
stesso che ripete poi l'inferno 26 a
proposito di ulisse
e questo aggettivo folle che si ripete
crea un ponte tra appunto dante
viaggiatore e ulisse altrettanto
viaggiatore e dunque dante stesso che ci
invita appunto a mettere a confronto
questi due modi diversi di viaggiare
ulisse come viaggia ulisse compie un
viaggio in superficie con più in viaggio
orizzontale mi piace rappresentarlo così
come il marinaio che cerca e guarda la
terra ulisse guarda avanti
forse il progresso non è l'upgrade
mentre dante è appunto l'upgrade il
miglioramento ulisse il progresso ulisse
colui che viaggia in superficie ulisse
parte da da itaca e raggiunge l'asia
minore [ __ ] per combattere la guerra di
[ __ ] a 10 anni appunto di
peregrinazioni nel mediterraneo poi
dante quando nel medioevo ancora non si
conoscevano integralmente iliade odissea
ma solo frammenti inventa un finale per
ulisse per cui ulisse per sete di
conoscenza ardore di conoscere senza va
oltre le colonne d'ercole e fa naufragio
dunque il viaggio di ulisse un viaggio
in superficie quello di dante invece un
viaggio in verticale non ci importa se
verso l'alto o verso il basso per a un
viaggio in verticale un viaggio in
profondità nulla avviene a caso in dante
tanto inizia la commedia con nel mezzo
dice nel ml in italiano è in più il
dante come se si dicesse io ci sono
dentro sono dentro le cose e non solo è
dentro le cose ma dante dice nel mezzo
ci sono fino in fondo ci sono dentro
proprio visceralmente ed ecco che quello
di dante secondo me è il modello di
viaggio vincente non a caso appunto
ulisse resterà all'inferno per quanto ci
si è presentato eroicamente mentre dante
appunto arriverà in in paradiso perché
dante appunto guarda le stelle la grande
lezione tant'è che proprio questa il
fatto che dante ci inviti ammirare le
stelle
desiderio dante l'ho definito franco
nembrini e poeta del desiderio
è il poeta che guarda le stelle non a
caso appunto ripeto nulla a casa in
dante ogni cantica termina con con la
parola stella stelle perché stella
appunto desiderio è ciò che cala
dall'alto sidus sideris il latino era la
stella e dunque
dante guarda verso l'alba versassi verso
il basso va sì verso verso gli inferi ma
è una metafora del del nostro essere del
viaggio che è la vita cioè cadere verso
il bar fino in fondo vivere l'inferno
per poi arrivare in purgatorio e infine
in paradiso dunque la la domanda che
tornando alla domanda che mi sono posto
che ho lasciato in sospeso si può dire
dunque che il mio percorso cioè quella
fotografia che vi ho fatto
ottimo ottimo maturità classica e
laurea con lode è stato un upgrade no mi
sono risposto no non lo è stato nella
misura in cui lo si considera come una
somma di ottimo e di lodi arrestato
nella misura in cui c'è stata piena
adesione tra il mio essere il mio modo
di sentire il mio desiderare e il mio
fare quindi l'invito che vi do ma
copiandolo appunto da da dante è per
fare appunto l'upgrade perché ci sia
miglioramento vivere in base al al
nostro desiderio alle nostre
inclinazioni alle nostre passioni a
quella fiamma che sono i nostri talenti
e quindi il mio invito che voglio
lasciarvi e che portiate a casa è
appunto quello di continuare a guardare
le stelle dunque guardare verso l'alto
fare un upgrade a punto grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]